[Musica]
credere a difficile
credere molto difficile
credo che credere sia forse una delle
cose più difficili che ci siano dopo le
verifiche di matematica
credere richiede una forza incredibile
richiede tantissimo coraggio
richiede
costanza
credere è difficile perché bisogna farlo
nonostante tutto nonostante gli ostacoli
nonostante
le difficoltà nonostante le nostre paure
nonostante tutto
si può credere veramente in un sacco di
cose si può credere in una religione si
può credere in un amore in una relazione
si può credere a un idea
molto bello che avere un'idea si può
credere in dei valori e degli ideali e
sono tutte strade molto difficili da da
percorrere
e crede davvero in qualcosa significa
affidarsi ad un incertezza totale
significa affidarsi ad un filo
sottilissimo
tra due sponde di un fiume che noi
dobbiamo attraversare e potrebbe
spezzarsi da un momento all'altro al
primo passo potrebbe spezzarsi
all'ultimissimo m
ma noi scegliamo di credere che non
succederà e che quindi ci porterà dove
siamo diretti
praticamente chi crede davvero in
qualcosa secondo me è un pazzo o
comunque cosciente utopista
cosa ci faccio qui
me lo sono chiesto quando mi hanno
contattato per venire a parlare con voi
sono molto felice di essere qui ero
davvero onorato ma ho anche molto
confuso
ero molto confuso perché gli è di solito
o un pubblico diverso ma questo di
solito non parlo
faccio altro
ma in qualche modo dovevo comunque
cercare di lasciare qualcosa e io adesso
non sono in grado di intraprendere tutte
le strade difficili di cui abbiamo
parlato pochissimo fa ma posso parlare
di ciò in cui ho creduto di più durante
tutta la mia vita che a me stesso
io sono edoardo spiazzante
ho 21 anni sono di ancona vivo a milano
e nella vita faccio musica
che è una frase che sono di dire da
quando sono molto piccoli
e fa un certo effetto dirla così davanti
a delle persone che ti ascoltano in
silenzio e e recepiscono
sostanzialmente scrivo arrangio ea volte
canto le mie canzoni
io diciamo quelli che quelli di voi che
mi conoscono realmente mi conoscono come
baltimora e vincitore dell'ultima
edizione di xfactor anche questo fa uno
strano effetto a dirlo
ma credo che che questo piccolissimo
step che che ho fatto nella nella mia
vita
sia ripetuto dal fatto che ho imparato
cosa vuol dire credere in me stesso e
ci tengo a sottrarre una differenza che
è quella tra imparare a credere e
cominciare a credere spesso si
utilizzano
queste cose queste queste due
affermazioni in in modo molto simile
invece secondo me imparare come credere
è fondamentale io per questo devo
ringraziare sicure anche i miei genitori
che sono stati degli insegnanti molto
validi quindi grazie mamma e grazie papà
e che mi hanno insegnato a sognare sì in
alto credere in me stesso spingere
sempre ma rimanere anche molto con i
piedi per terra
io sono cresciuto con con internet sono
nativo digitale
e
a 7 anni giocavo a cityville su facebook
so quanti di voi giocavano a siti su
facebook spero molti come un account
falso di mio padre a 10 scaricavo i
giochi sul pc di mia nonna che sia
ovviamente fuso perché era un pc da
nonna
non credo esistano abbastanza nonne da
creare la società non è con un computer
per creare la sottocategoria
pc da nonna ma se esistesse quel
computer ci sarebbe sicuramente
rientrato
fatto sta che giro su internet da quando
sono nato e su tutti i vari siti i blog
adesso su tutti i social va sempre molto
di moda il self improvement l'essere la
versione migliore di se stessi e il
credere nonostante tutto eccetera
eccetera e alcune di alcune di queste di
queste persone che ne parlano sono molto
preparate sono bravissime danno dei
consigli incredibili e migliorano la
vita delle persone moltissimi secondo me
sono riassumibili sotto un unico grande
macro concetto molto pericoloso e molto
fuorviante se non si sta attenti che
quello del basta crederci
volere è potere
credi fermamente in te stesso e verrà
ricompensato sicuramente
secondo me è molto e molto pericoloso
questa
questa affermazione perché
crederci crederci e basta
nella maniera sbagliata
può essere molto noto sbagliato e quindi
bisogna credere nella maniera giusta
io ho sempre creduto
di poter fare musica nella vita più che
altro ho sempre creduto che avrei fatto
musica nella vita perché per me non era
un opzione per me era neanche un
obiettivo era semplicemente l'unica
strada percorribile
e
diciamo non credo nel piano b non credo
nella nella sicurezza messa da parte
perché secondo me può fare da deterrente
a tutto l'impegno a tutta la fatica che
richiede per seguire un sogno
per seguire un sogno vorrei partire da
un po più indietro
vorrei partire da me in prima liceo ii
liceo
14 15 anni momento delle rivelazioni
della vita
importantissime pitti cambia tutto da un
momento all'altro per esempio una
mattina mi sono svegliato e mi sono reso
conto che dovevo farmi passi
sono orribili i bassi che ti vengono da
adolescente e devo dire che mi ha
migliorato la vita a tagliarmi bassi
quindi vi invito a tagliarmi i baffi
la seconda rivelazione che ho avuto è
stata
pensa alla tua vita per i prossimi 50
anni smetti di credere che fare
l'ingegnere perché la matematica non è
come quella che pensavi alle medie
e trova qualcosa che vuoi fare davvero
tutta la vita
io mi sono risposto solo musica come vi
dicevo
solamente che è molto difficile per un
ragazzo di quell'età andrea dei propri
genitori andare io sono nato da mia
mamma io voglio fare le canzoni in tutto
e rimandare no
però insomma in qualche modo avrei
dovuto farlo giustamente un genitore
pensa a a una sicurezza pensa sempre al
piano b
e spesso vuole che sia il piano ha
giustamente io però volevo fare questa
cosa qui quindi a casa avevo un computer
avevo un microfono
con gli amici avevo cominciato a parte
registrare le mie di canzoni anche
registrare delle loro poi hanno
cominciato a venire amici di amici e
stavano diciamo arrivando delle cose
insomma lavoravo
poi mi hanno chiamato persone che non
conoscevo dicendo che volevano appunto
venire studio da me lavorare con me
e questo ha portato dei risultati
i risultati convincono diciamo spesso
e
[Musica]
men che non si dica quindi sono con i
primi guadagni ha costruito uno studio e
con l'aiuto dei miei genitori ovviamente
da prima ed era diventato un produttore
facevo le strumentali le basi così
chiamate per per tanti rapper della zona
scrivevo le canzoni con i cantautori che
venivano da me voler andavo oppure
finito di scriverlo con loro o le
scrivevo per loro
insomma con questo ho avuto
l'opportunità di conoscere veramente
tantissimi ragazzi tantissimi artisti
no anzi non necessariamente ragazzi
anche persone adulte
e tutte queste persone avevano una cosa
in comune fortissima che era il credere
in se stessi e
forse
qui
ricollegarmi a all'idea di come credere
loro credevano veramente molto forte in
se stessi ma
forse non avevano imparato a credere
diciamo nessuno nasce con la capacità di
costruire una casa no
non esistono neonati che costruiscono
case
per fortuna forse
c'è chi però chi ci prova lo stesso e
magari mettendo mattoni 34 arrivati da
sul muro 2 poi mettere un mattone boom
cade tutto lui non si fa a grosse
domande
riprende a costruire costruisce un altro
non ricade e così all'infinito e alla
fine non riesce a costruire una casa c'è
invece chi
arriva stoffa non so dove metterlo
questo mattone allora studia e fa tanta
pratica chiede aiuto e una volta che è
in grado di valutare il proprio lavoro è
in grado di distinguere delle fondamenta
fatte bene delle fondamenta fallaci è in
grado di collegare tutti i fili
dell'elettricità i tubi dell'acqua
conosce tutti i dettagli di come si
costruisce una casa va e la fa
ovviamente la sua casa non sarà mai
invincibile o indistruttibile potrebbe
avere dei piccoli errori potrebbe avere
delle sbavature di progettazione
potrebbe arrivare un terremoto buttarla
giù gli auguriamo di no ovviamente
ma se dovesse succedere questa seconda
persona sarebbe sicuramente in grado
di rendersi conto di aver sbagliato
qualcosa cercherebbe un errore prima o
poi lo troverebbe lo risolverebbe e
smetterebbe di usare cognitivi
io ho scritto canzoni quando ho
cominciato a scrivere canzoni quando
avevo 11 12 anni
e non lo è non le facevo sentire a
nessuno
ma mi faceva sentire nessuno non perché
mi vergogna o perché avessi paura del
giudizio di qualcun altro
ma perché non le ritenevo all'altezza
non non pensavo che che le mie canzoni
fossero come quelle che sentiamo in
radio fossero come quelle dei miei
artisti preferiti
non sapevo cosa mancasse ma sapevo che
non erano al livello necessario è sicuro
che se gli facessi sentire le prime 50
100 canzoni che ho scritto
probabilmente vi mettereste prima un po
ridere
e poi insomma vi chiederete
perché sono qui con che qualifica con
che faccia a parlarvi la prima canzone
che ho scritto erano orribili ma
terrificanti
al tempo non mi rendo conto fossero
veramente così brutte ma
insomma appunto sapevo che non era il
massimo
e
il massimo
cos'è il massimo bella domanda
io credo
fortissimo m e credevo in me anche a 12
anni
ma credo e credevo e spero di continuare
sempre a credere di poter essere
migliore di poter ambire a qualcosa di
più di non accontentarmi mai il problema
di quei ragazzi che con cui ho fatto
tantissima musica e che ho conosciuto
veramente in una maniera intima e
profonda come solo vernante scrivere una
canzone insieme può può fare può creare
questo legame incredibile
si erano accontentati si sono
accontentati la maggior parte
hanno abbandonato i loro sogni perché
non hanno raggiunto immediatamente i
loro obiettivi credevano fortissimo a
loro stessi non ce l'hanno fatta
ok basta
invece bisogna credere di poter
migliorare bisogna
credere di poter essere il massimo e non
ci si arriva mai ovviamente
però è un po come la classica salita
perenne della vita c'è sempre una
scalata e
quindi
nonostante
oggi magari sia
sia sia stata una giornata fruttuosa
domande lo sarà di più e domani sarà
meglio di oggi sono sicuro che tra 10
anni scriverò canzoni
spero migliori di quella che ho scritto
stamattina ieri sera
tutto questo per dire un pochino che
l'autostima è sicuramente il motore del
mondo ma va bilanciata da tanta
conoscenza e tanta
coscienza di se
credete responsabilmente
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]